all right leona
leona where did you grow up where are
you from where are you
i'm from north of chicago um
about an hour town called grays lake
okay
of chicago
yeah
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad
yeah um
very uh supportive loving parents um
yeah
little brother good childhood yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
overachiever
student athlete um
i
was in the top 10 in state track in the
1600 meters is my best event like um
every year so you're a good student yeah
i was a good student an athlete and
um
yeah it was a good i had a good high
school career did you go to college as
well yes
i went to uh rice university
and ran track there
and did well in track and um
steeplechase was my event and
was ranked in the top 20 in my last year
of college in steeplechase
so i'm going to ask the obvious question
how did you end up working in a strip
club
if you have such a nice
well as a student um i mean so if you
spend any time in strip clubs maybe you
have
there's a there's a
a whole range of
uh girls with different experiences and
um i've worked with girls with master's
degrees
um
so
stripping is
is a i went into it um interested in the
feminist question of i've read some
articles and things that there's talk at
the time five years ago and there still
is talk about
um sex work and stripping being
empowering
and um so i went into it
with that question in mind
um
and
i
am somebody who loves movies and costume
and performance and dance
and um and
i've also
i'm somebody that wants to challenge any
kind of preconceptions or biases i might
have and
um and biases that other people have and
to investigate stigma
um my mom is has very traditional sorts
of uh
outlooks on on
things and you know
um
about sex work prostitution all these
things and
um
i wanted to
investigate that because i didn't
believe the stories that she was telling
about it and the way that the media
talks about stripping and sex work
so i went into it with all these
questions and it's been a really
fascinating um five years of
um and a lot of realism you know
discovering that actually yes all of the
you know
some of the well yeah the the way that
society um
wants to pigeonhole sex workers and tell
one story about sex work and
um
and about strippers and all these
stereotypes about strippers
um and and
about women
a lot of it carries over to women and
it's all
[Music]
it's of course the truth is more
complicated
so it always is
yeah is this almost like an experiment
for you or is it are you trying to
survive and pay bills
um
i could do other things i have a degree
um
and
uh
i'm going to school now so um
but
it's something that has continued to
draw me in and
initially you know i was working retail
when i came here
and
um and
i mean
the irony you know the obvious
like
uh
thing for me with people talking about
strippers and sex workers selling their
bodies
um i was selling my body selling my time
selling my
emotional
labor my intelligence to a company
working retail
40 hours a week making maybe 2 000
a month for that
um people who work minimum wage jobs at
mcdonald's they're selling
their
their time and their bodies and
everything for
for pennies
you know not pennies but not not a
livable wage and um
and so uh
i think that sex work and stripping is
just
um
a more you know it's more lucrative and
gives you a lot more flexibility to
pursue other you know things that to
invest your time in in passion projects
things that actually are actualize
yourself
um so it's it's a great gig
so i've stuck with it for that too you
like the money you're making
yeah i mean the money is great the
flexibility is great the people i my
co-workers are
fantastic like even running women's
track i've never
felt more camaraderie and
um like more
apart belonging to a group of women as i
do among strippers
um that's interesting yeah uh just
really independent-minded creative women
um
and
uh just
down to earth like
i mean strippers
don't have to
don't have this don't hold on to this
pretension about being a pure or like
woman you know
um
and i think all of that is bs and i've
learned that through this work you're at
a topless club not a fully nude club
right i worked at fully nude clubs i've
worked in fully nude clubs yeah
um
i've worked the gamut of different is
there much different is there much
difference between the two
um
the nude clubs are typically set up as
gentlemen's clubs um
where you spend a lot of time in like
vip rooms so but in terms of the the
type of women that will work there and
um there's a little bit of a there's a
spectrum just in terms of what women are
comfortable with
um
women of all different backgrounds work
in every different type of club but it
just depends on
what what they're comfortable with like
exposing their bodies and
that's a personal decision yeah are
there
some of the stereotypical
girls that are lost and on drugs that
are
working at some of the clubs you've been
to yes um
yeah that's that's definitely
um
a situation uh that happens and
um
[Music]
and
but at the same time
um
it for people that are lost and they
don't have many options
um sex work will always be there
and
i'm
i
i just find it so
outrageous outrageous and
um makes me so mad that
our government and our laws and our
culture and our people can't stand
beside and behind women who
do sex work
because
sex workers
provide a valuable service in society
they provide companionship
emotional support physical touch
love for
for
customers
customers also face taboo in this
industry
um
and
the
the politics of
of the way that politicians
uh talk about sex work or
like sex trafficking is part of the
discussion too it's all political and
it's and they are trading on
um the power of a puritanical tradition
in american society and gaining power
from that and um
and
it's it's just disgusting it
it makes me really mad at the hypocrisy
of it um
you're not a prostitute but do you think
prostitution should be legalized
absolutely
um it's the oldest profession
um
the uh
the arguments against it are
crazy to me because so people talk about
sex trafficking
of course um that's a problem and it's a
grave problem
um
and
at the same time um
there will always be
p women who who want to sell sex and and
should be able to and have a right to
to have sex on their own terms whatever
those terms are with anyone they want
um
and
the
like why should we not protect the women
that want to do this consensually on
their own terms um there's trafficking
in many other industries uh housekeeping
um
farming
uh and yet we don't shut down those
industries and make them illegal because
we're concerned about the
um
the people and of course we should be
concerned about people that are um
trafficked
um
but it doesn't excuse
abandoning the
the uh the welfare of
of sex workers
in your
your family you have a father in your
life as well
oh yeah i have a great relationship with
both my parents and they know you're
doing this um yeah
what was there my dad's pretty amused by
it um
i think he thinks of it as a phase
that's fine
i'm 30. you're 30.
my mom hates it she's as i said she's
has traditional outlook on these things
and i've had so many frustrating
circuitous conversations with her about
about
stripping and prostitution and
everything in my views and
it always comes down to her saying
well i'll never see you know i'm just
different
you're not going to convince me and she
can't
with anyone that you really dig in on
those that are those arguments against
um sex work it it there's no reasons
behind it it's always just comes down to
well it's just me i can't change so
that that is a that's always a red flag
for um
bias and and bigotry honestly yeah well
your midwestern parents are probably
yeah i mean i understand like
open-minded about this kind of stuff is
right
more conservative um they're not real
risk-takers um
they're yeah but i mean they've done
well in life and i respect their their
decisions in life they um but they don't
really uh
yeah they they don't necessarily under
understand it but the other other areas
of your life seem to be i don't know you
very well i mean are you into drugs at
all
uh no no
you're going to school yeah
you look healthy as can be so
and you're intelligent so it seems like
you could
probably claim that you're just
doing this you know just for the money
and
i could it's probably good exercise it
is a good exercise it's as i said it's a
lot of things for me it's been very
meaningful to me
um
and
and i and i i cares i've been involved
with activism um
within the industry to try to change it
um strip clubs uh are
very exploitative
environments for the women that work
there
the vast majority of dancers are not
paid to work
not even a minimum wage
and it's all based on what you can make
in tips
and
so actually the first club i worked at i
ended up getting fired after a year
because i brought up the labor law
problems i was like
we're not independent contractors we're
clearly employees
we have to work on your terms as the
owners of the club um and they said well
if you don't like the rules you can
leave they were charging late fees for
scheduling and it's like if i'm an
independent contractor you can't tell me
when i when i'm gonna work and charge me
for being late um so i ended up suing
them i got a settlement um because and
that's what happens when when strippers
do strip clubs they win because the law
is cut and dried and it's even clearer
in california than it was before
so i've been down that road and
now strippers are classified the ab5
law that passed in 2018
makes it very clear
that
strippers and a lot of other
people who are commonly misclassified
are employees it makes the test simpler
the legal test
and as employees you can unionize i mean
servers were always employees could
always unite but now it's very clear and
so
that's the next frontier for the
industry right now and there was
actually a club in the 90s called the
lusty lady in san francisco and it was a
peep show and those girls unionized and
it's an amazing story there's um
good books about it that the some of the
girls have written
and um and then they actually the owners
uh
sold them the club and they ran it as a
worker co-op for a decade um
and so that's a very inspirational uh
story going forward i i want to make
change within the industry um
before you know i transition
um into
the next phase of my life
um
and so uh
so yeah it's kind of an exciting time um
i worked with a group called strippers
united
that
that works on this problem and
yeah and now i'm working with a few
other dancers to start a stripper co-op
we want to do pop-up shows and raise
money to ultimately open our own club
and
run it
um
ourselves and
that's how it should be done i mean the
women the sex work you know strippers
and sex workers should be in control of
their work because it's their bodies on
the line they should um get all the the
profits and and
they
we need to be in control why should
anyone else be making money off of our
bodies
so so it sounds like you're not
you've often i'll ask somebody if they
get depressed or anxious or angry or
anything about
doing sex work and i assume your answer
is no
um it's a hard job
i mean there are bad days at work for
sure
it's uh i think of strippers and sex
workers as on the front lines of
misogyny um because because of the
stigma in society
that's part of it but it's part of it
just some men are pigs and [ __ ] and
um
and so you have to face the brunt of
that and it does get hard but
but i i watched another one interviews
one of
the girls said it was very character
building
and it is and you develop a way of
brushing off the negativity
it's very strengthening i think and
yeah the women who've been in the
industry for a long time are just
masters at negotiation and sales and
and keeping a a cool head and making
their money and using so much respect
for them there's probably some great
skills you're learning from doing this
that you can apply towards other careers
oh absolutely i mean a lot of women go
on to be real estate agents and do
really well because they're great at
making the sale and
um
and it's just there's there's so many
skills i mean therapists women go on to
be therapists too because those are all
the skills that you're using in the job
you're having to appeal to yeah and when
you sit down with a customer you have to
appeal to what you think they want and
that's that's what sales is about i'm
not a very good salesperson because
um i can't i have a hard time
just
just you know like really reading people
and kind of just come to it as myself
and i'm just like well this is what you
get um
um but for for the women that are
natural sales people my mom is a
salesperson she's the same way like i
have a lot of respect for that and
and
you know there's other so i was thinking
on the way over here like i was an
athlete i was an elite athlete and
professional athletes it's also a
short-lived career
and you do have to think about
transitioning out of it and yet when i
left running in college they were like
put this on your resume it'll it'll be a
great benefit and and people will see
how hard working you are and how you can
manage your time and
strippers should be able to put that on
their resume and it should be something
that people have respect for because
it's very hard work and
um and it uses so many interpersonal
skills like people talk about soft
skills it's it's just like
it's the most you can do i say that
strippers and sex workers get paid to do
what society normally expects of women
just to do for free which is to be
emotionally supportive to be
beautiful and
um
and
you know to to do all these things that
that people talk about like as
you know well soft skills you know being
being personable and everything and
i don't know women work hard in society
the strippers work really hard and we
should be acknowledged and celebrated
for that
tell me about the men that come to the
strip clubs
that's another thing that that people
want to
paint a broad picture of the strip club
customer my mom says oh you know like oh
you know
like
you know i told her i met a billionaire
in the store club and i did he
started in the film industry early on
and created a vfx company visual effects
and was in on the early stages of it and
he made a ton of money and now he works
on different passion projects he's you
know got restaurants and everything like
that and he's a billionaire um and
she couldn't believe it you know she
wants to think that all strip club
customers are just like
you know
ogres and whatever
um people who
who are desperate and like don't have a
life or whatever
um but that's the stigma and that
customers face
um
and you you meet a whole
spectrum of people in the strip club um
and it's it's people that are seeking
out uh that companionship and a lot of
cases and sometimes people just want to
have a fun time and party
um
we are entertainers and
um
and
friends to customers
and uh
but yeah i mean of course there's
disgusting men that come in that don't
want to spend any money
if you go to a strip club
you've got to
bring them bring money to spend on the
girls period you can't show up at the
strip club and spend expect to spend
four hours there with like 50 bucks in
your pocket um i'd say like a hundred
dollars for like an hour or maybe two if
you want to stretch it but that's don't
stretch it you know be generous
you're going to a temple of uh where you
can have the opportunity to worship
women and everything that you know that
women are about and and also
you know and femininity and all these
concepts we have about women
yeah so it's very frustrating sometimes
especially it's mostly frustrating when
guys are cheap
what have you learned about men from
doing this
um
men are
also confined by
the stereotypes and expectations of them
in society
the gender binary hurts both both sides
and
yeah i think i think men struggle with
um the same things that women struggle
with
for the same reasons basically
um
men are really want to get in touch with
their sensitive
side um
and
feel
like romantic emotions like a lot of
times
like guys with the club customers it's
it's just wonderful to kind of see them
like kind of melt before you and and
get you know be really mesmerized by a
beautiful performance a lot of them
appreciate the art of the dancing
um
and
and
you know some men
just it will you know men have privilege
in society and you can see that come
through a lot too
um
with their lack of understanding for
some of the struggles that women go
through or they just have sort of
single-mindedness
and don't have a lot of like
i guess
they have a harder time kind of like
thinking about people around them
so
um i mean men are complicated i guess i
can't say that i've learned anything
specific about men just that everyone's
human
[Music]
what's the craziest thing you've seen
working
you've been working how long in the
clubs
uh it's like five years five years
you've seen some crazy stuff i said
um
i don't know i mean no the
does
does doing this kind of work undermine
your self-esteem or does it build it up
sounds like it builds no yeah i i have a
lot of um
i like it's the it's the i love being
naked on stage it's just like
i feel great about my body and
um i think being naked and flaunting
your your stuff is very
can feel really good
um
yeah so i i and i've built skills i'm
gaining a lot of confidence just after
five five years kind of maturing as a
stripper
i like to i'm really gaining a lot of
i feel very rewarded by
being
an escape for people that people can
come to the club like regular customers
and meet with me and they can just
like escape their lives into this and
having a wonderful entertainment you
know time and um finding refuge in me as
somebody that can just listen to the
what's going on in their lives
and it's an escape for them it's almost
like you're a therapist sometimes yeah
yeah and that's part of what we do and i
it's very rewarding to be able to be
that for someone um
so that's
that's also empowering does it affect
your personal life your romantic life um
just in terms of the time i have i have
a wonderful boyfriend who's uh supports
what i do and we're very much in love
and
um
and
so
only to the extent that you know working
takes time crazy hours
no not really i work like two or three
nights a week but i guess i'm just
reflecting on this last week this last
week was crazy because i had to do some
sewing for a friend and and and for a
film shoot and
i don't know and then and then it was
his birthday so we had a party on
saturday but
so sometimes life gets in the way of of
quality time with your partner as it
does for anybody
i guess
you're you're probably the exception to
most of the girls working
in these clubs though i would think
i don't think so
no i work with with women who
have very
like i guess normal lives like
uh women who who own houses because of
the
of the success they've had in the
industry um and everyone is
is living their life i don't know i mean
i think people would be shocked like
people who've
who haven't really met strippers if they
spend any time in the dressing room to
hear
girls talk about you know like
um
you know i'm really busy with school
work or
um
you know i i like families and they have
some women have kids and they're working
to support their families and
just regular people
like doing a job
and some some i think some younger girls
get kind of sucked into the party
lifestyle that can happen
um because you are you know professional
entertainer um
but i think
like a lot of young women go to college
and get sucked into the party lifestyle
it's just being young you know
and
you know younger strippers baby
strippers sometimes spend their money on
designer stuff and don't save it as much
but i mean i was prone to that i spent
like four thousand dollars in marc
jacobs like within a month when i first
came to l.a
so everybody's prone to that i think we
can all understand that
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life in my
life yeah
oh
that's a big question
the most important thing um
i mean
i i guess i'm learning to accept
like
the humanity of of people that everyone
makes mistakes to accept myself mistakes
in myself that i've made and
be just more accepting of everyone's
struggle and
i've i do a lot of meditation and i've
kind of studied meditation and
um
yeah i suppose
yeah accepting people for who they are
and i and through meditation i've sort
of developed kind of like a
deterministic worldview i guess you
could say um i think that if it was and
actually this the club kind of taught me
this if it was if it was going to happen
it was always going to happen if it
doesn't happen it was never going to
happen because
if you're comparing yourself to other
girls getting dances with other or you
talk to a customer for like 20 minutes
and then you know he says oh i don't
really want to dance right now you're
like okay i'll check back with you and
then another girl sits down and he takes
her off right away um that's not
personal to you
and there's nothing you could have done
about it if he was never going to get a
dance with you he just never was
um and the other girl was what he was
looking for
um
and so that's been a really great
learning experience um
when i say meditation you're meditating
and you're supposed to watch like
observe basically the flow of your
experience your thoughts
sounds feelings
and just see them float through your
consciousness and you realize that you
don't think your thoughts your thoughts
just pop into your mind and then you
know after the fact we ascribe control
to um to ourselves and to our thoughts
and we think oh i thought that or i
could have done differently
um if you actually think about the past
could you have really done anything
differently than you have in your life
and i don't think so and and so that's
about accepting people for who they are
everyone's born into this world in
certain circumstances and
have certain personalities and
um tendencies and and we just live out
our lives and and our environment
changes and
things we don't have control over and i
really don't think we have much control
over anything and the bottom of it
um
so
yeah
interesting all right leona thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
good luck it's a pleasure thank you
you